some people call us strong
we hold multiple records for outrageous
feats of strength but how does our idea
of super strength translate in other
cultures find out as we put our muscles
to the test as we travel the globe
seeking the limits of human ability for
their fellow strongmen hello
Scotland showing the people of Scotland
are very American brand of strength
today dozens of Highland Games around
the world during the summer months if we
want to find out what it means to be a
strong man in Scotland we're gonna need
a crash course Jason Young and Malcolm
Cleghorn are two of the best between
them they've won more than 100 Highland
Games Hylas their job to coach us and
make us better so we can compete in the
Cal games the biggest Highland Games in
the nation hired a college scholarship
for the Olympic hammer throw the
experience helps the release is perfect
okay at Lisa's ballon I just need more
speed then right slightly must beat you
there you go he's getting a little bit
better so once he gets the technique
down that's game over he's got more
power you'll see how it works but that's
no but oh my god kill the tree I brought
over here I got stuck the next time we
meet on the field it'll be at the Cal
games will be competing against our new
coaches so a hope all this extra insight
has prepared us
I just can't believe we're here
will our strength be muscle enough here
in Scotland it's time to find out
Paul 324 good not through 22 you like
poufy yeah yeah well we're training with
Jason we were doing two rotations yeah
so I think we need to do two rotations
there otherwise I mean my god these guys
are beating us about 30-40 feet
not bad oh yeah
in the end our longest throws top 88
feet I came over here and I didn't come
in last I actually beat a couple people
including my brother Scotty strong men
and the crowd what we're good at first
thing we're gonna do Craig is gonna
stand behind the stack of concrete and
drive his head through the concrete
stack we've got two feet of concrete
come on help me man cheer